it's always wonderful to connect with
another person you know and in my
viewpoint unit rankings are one of the
most noble persons on the planet today
so lesson one is finding food because
their mothers have been killed and it's
a mother we pass on the cultural
traditions and the knowledge on how to
find food in the forest so we have to
replace that stage to is when they're
making a night nests and staying
overnight but we're monitoring from dawn
to dusk each day this is actually very
good because we don't want penny to be
wanting to be and feel that she can go
close to humans we want the health is
fishing
I think those can display and educate
people with a variety of animals we do
perfectly well and captives in quite
happy but animals such as orangutan
simply can't it always feels good for
when you know they're they can return
independent to the wild yeah she's up
there cool just came out of her day nest
and now might change to this so we
couldn't ask for more
you